[Music]
I'm gonna make it real simple edit a
bottle of
it's a great man
I'm here to support him and not having
it fear
and make it short but I'm a hundred
behind his humanity and he's been a
great great friend of mine and to the
league
that's all these years thank you
thank you Jim Derrick Brooks here and
again if there's a great day for mr.
Barlow and his family and obviously I've
been at the front a lot of the goodwill
and the thing is that mr. Navarro has
been able to do in changing the lives of
our kids in Tampa Florida and all the
work that he and his foundation has done
I can't sit up here and give you all the
stories about it but it's been very
impactful that I've been able to partner
with him since 2005 and I am fritz and
educating our youth to make them better
citizens for tomorrow and again standing
here to be a proud partner appears in
our collegiate high school it's just one
of the many things that he can attend
Stu and deserving of this point in here
today so again I just thank God for the
opportunity to continue to serve
alongside him and again thank you guys
for your time
but afternoon we're excited to be here
for all the right reasons you know you
think of people that are in your life
that find a way to help you live with a
certain compass and you find yourself
realizing that in a day like this it's
great because of the fact that he
understands not only its compass but
what he can achieve and so we're really
excited for mr. Barlow and all what he's
done for all of us and he's just been a
an incredible friend incredible owner
and we'll always be indebted to him um
I'm Charles Taylor I was one mister D
has been he's been he's been more than I
only been he's been a father figure he's
been a helper he's a warrior and you
know the elephant in the room is you
know what we all make mistakes and today
the president cleared that mistake from
it but the man that he is the man that
he stands for
is there a testament to the life that
he's lived from day one and and how he
impacted our lives you know I have to
get bilateral knee surgery and I suppose
did it today but I would not miss this
day because I know this man's heart I
know what I know what he's done for
players that play for him I've nobody
does the kids in the community
he's just a powerful man and I said
proud to be here that support
Mississippi well 30 years ago I got the
opportunity to play the greatest game
ever NFL football and it was because of
Eddie DeBartolo and also Bill Walsh in
that organization and it was all about
family that's really what they stood for
and that's the reason why I think we won
so many championships is so many ball
games so Eddie was like that 12th man
that was on that football field and you
know that this guy you know he wanted us
to win and I think he's the main reason
why we won so many Super Bowls so today
is a great day for him I'm glad to be
here be a part of that and you know it's
just something I'll never forget
you know this man he has done so much in
the community has done so much in NFL
football and today is a great day for
all time what does this mean to you what
did he say to you there well it's really
just about Eddie DeBartolo that's it
so basically you know I think with Eddie
and what he has accomplished what he has
done on the football field off the
football field a lot of charity work so
we talked about that we talked about
just being great you know trying to be
the greatest of all time and you know I
take my head off to Donald Trump for
what he did and and you know like I said
it's all about just being here for Eddie
today
you know for me in echo and Jays
sentiments you know I know miserable I
didn't play for him so I got a chance to
get to know him through all of our civic
duties in terms of serving our youth
through education and to me that's
that's not about a status in society
that's the status about someone that has
a willing heart in a desire to give
something back to someone else and
understand alongside me with that
platform so that's what we've been doing
leaders since 2005 together but that's
what he and his family has been doing in
terms of serving and others in
communities that don't get a lot of
attention and they do a lot without a
lot of fanfare quite honest with you and
again the work that we do together in
Temple a lot of that is done behind the
scenes with without a lot of attention
but a lot more impact to doing that so
for me in terms of speaking to mr.
Barlow I look at the core core character
of a person that I've been able to get
to know quite honest which for the last
18 years
general do you has available for
individual interviews
you